[Musik]
es ist eine traurige Wahrheit unserer
Zeit Rüstungsgüter sind derzeit so
gefragt wie nie zuvor da tobt seit fast
einem Jahr der Krieg in der Ukraine die
ganze Welt befürchte dass China Taiwan
angreifen könnte Nordkorea stelle ich
mit Raketen und bedroht seine Nachbarn
der Iran so die Sorge der
Weltgemeinschaft könnte mit einem Krieg
von inneren Problemen ablenken also
weiter und so fort die Liste der
Konflikte Erde ist extrem lang und sie
wird nicht kürzer spätestens seit dem
Überfall der Russen auf die Ukraine will
sich jedes Land der Welt für angegriffen
schützen und im Ernstfall während können
und genau deshalb laufen derzeit überall
die Rüstung schmieden heiß hier auf
diese wahlpolitik haben wir euch bereits
erzählt dass Länder wie Australien Polen
Deutschland und Japan eine starke
Erhöhung ihrem Militärausgaben
angekündigt haben und derzeit kräftig
aufrüsten ich werde euch die
entsprechenden Videos unten in der
Beschreibung verlinken damit aber so
viele westliche Länder gleichzeitig
aufrüsten können braucht es nicht nur
mehr Geld es braucht auch genügend
industrielle und technologische
Kapazitäten um die Ausrüstung
rechtzeitig herstellen und liefern zu
können aber so offensichtlich das auch
erscheint es ist in war eine echtes
Problem denn die ganze Welt will jetzt
in kurzer Zeit Waffen haben
wir sprechen hier also von riesigen
aufregen und Mengen hier mal ein
Hausnummer ius Militärindustrie hat
allein in der zweiten Juli-Hälfte 2022
Verträge über 20 Milliarden US-Dollar
geschlossen stellt euch das mal vor 20
Milliarden für den Verkauf von Waffen
und militärischer Ausrüstung in nur zwei
Wochen im gesamten Zeitraum ist das also
mehr als eine Milliarde pro Tag Heimat
F35 Raketen Torpedos auch bisschen
Panzerfahrzeuge praktisch der gesamte
Katalog der konventionellen US-Waffen
verkauft sich die Arme Semmel die
Verkäufe sämtliche amerikanische Rüstung
sind drastisch in die Höhe gestellt und
die Nachfrage ist ungebremst
[Musik]
in der Krieg in der Ukraine hat zwei
Dinge gezeigt erstens dass die
westlichen Länder stärkere Armeen
brauchen und zweitens das amerikanische
Waffen immer noch die erste Wahl sind
und zwar mit großem Abstand zur
Konkurrenz
das Problem ist dass die
Produktionskapazität der
us-militärindustrie natürlich nicht
unbegrenzt ist es braucht nun mal Zeit
um eine ganze Produktionslinie an einer
so groß und plötzliche Nachfrage
anzupassen denn wie ihr wisst was sagt
andres Handy Ukraine mit Waffen was aber
wegen des hohen Verbrauchs schon mal zu
längeren Lieferzeiten bei anderen Kunden
führen
US-Waffen aber Washington liefert sie
nicht das ist nur ein Beispiel aber
Lieferverzögerungen und endlose
wackelisten sind inzwischen die Regeln
und dann gibt es noch ein weiteres
Problem amerikanische Waffen sind zwar
die Grande Rüstungsgüter aber sie sind
auch furchtbar teuer nicht nur in Bezug
auf den einmaligen Kaufpreis sondern
auch in Bezug auf die laufenden Kosten
für ihren Einsatz diese beiden Faktoren
treiben viele Länder dazu nach
Alternativen zu suchen und zwar nach
technologisch fortschrittlichen
Alternativen denn wer will schon die
Sicherheit eines Landes wegen
minderwertigen Materials auf Spiel
setzen und glaub mir viele Länder die
bisher bei den Russen gekauft haben
jetzt ganz gewaltig angesetzt dessen was
sie in der Ukraine zu sehen bekommen
[Musik]
tja viele Möglichkeiten gibt es da also
nicht mehr außer einer Philippinen
erhalten Waffen und Ausrüstung aus
Südkorea Ägypten wird zum neuen Markt
zur koreanische Waffenexporte Polen und
Südkorea unterzeichnen
milliardenschwerden waffenvertrag die
Philippinen Ägypten Polen Norwegen
Australien die Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate Finnland Estland die Türkei egal
über welchen Kontinent wir sprechen
immer mehr Länder richten ihre Augenmerk
auf südkoreanische Waffen um ihre
Streitkräfte zu modernisieren oder zu
ergänzen sogar Washington selbst
behandelt derzeit über die Lieferung von
10.000 modernen geschossen für die
Artillerie diese sollen dann wiederum in
der Ukraine zum Einsatz kommen aber
warum ausgerechnet Südkorea aus welchem
Grund wessen Länder wie z.B Polen so
stark auf rüstungshersteller aus diesem
Land in diesem Video werden wir euch
natürlich alle Antworten liefern und ich
verspreche euch ihr werdet verdammt
überragt sein wie groß das kleines
Südkorea bereits jetzt ist wenn es
Umrüstung und Militärtechnik geht für
mich aber vorher noch einen kurzen
werbeinweis unseres tollen Sponsors zur
Aufschlag einfügen damit wir danach
sofort zur Touch reiten können denn
surfshark hat nicht nur das heutige
Video wirklich gemacht nein es hat auch
ein VPN im Angebot das wirklich
empfehlenswert und vor allem sicher und
vertrauenswürdig ist so lockt es zum
Beispiel selbstverständlich keinerlei
Verbindung Daten mit natürlich kann ein
Virtual Private Network und VPN einen
nicht vor allen Gefahren du musst nach
wie vor Umsicht walten lassen und wissen
was man tut aber es stellt hier für ein
Werkzeug mit leicht näheren Vorteilen
darf zum einen erschwert ist in
Kombination mit anderen Vorkehrungen
eure Aktionen nachzuverfolgen und
abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener
an einem anderen Ort so könnt ihr zum
Beispiel auch Website und
Internetdienste zugreifen in dem Land in
den gerade seitlich verfügbar werden ob
daheim oder in Urlaub damit schlagt
jetzt sind nur und Gio blocking ein
Schnäppchen Netflix und anderes
anbieten von Europa oder deutsches
Internet fernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
kein Problem und das ist noch lange
nicht alles damit nur einem surfshark
kommt dann könnt ihr wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte MV in registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode Politik die
hier angeht bekommt ihr von surfshark
auch noch einen Rabatt in Höhe von 83%
und oben seine ersten drei Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nicht viel los besorgt haben
damit auch gleichzeitig uns finanzieren
unter die Arme das könnte übrigens auch
direkt mit Hilfe eines Spenden links den
ich euch ebenfalls in die Beschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung bei den damit hättet ihr
uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und noch
bessere Videos zu liefern so und nun
schnallt euch an es geht ab nach
Südkorea
not macht erfinderisch
die südkoreanische Rüstungsindustrie
erlebt derzeit einen gewaltigen Buben
sie tritt zweifelsohne in einem goldenes
Zeitalter ein Südkorea ist auf dem
besten Weg die Nummer 4 der
Rüstungsexporteure zu werden laut dem
Korea Institute of economics and trade
la Corea im Jahr 2021 auf dem 9 Platz
der weltweiten Rüstungsexporte mit den
diesjährigen Experten würde Korea auf
den vierten Platz vor Rücken hinter den
rüstungsriesen USA Russland und
Frankreich mit anderen Worten südkorea
hat vielleicht sogar schon China
überholt die Südkoreaner schätzen dass
sie 2022 Verträge überwachen Export in
Wert von fast 20 Milliarden Dollar
abgeschlossen haben das liegt weit über
den von der Regierung gesetzten Ziel von
15 Milliarden Dollar und man könnte
denken das Ganze sei nur eine
vorübergehende Erscheinung eine
Eintagsfliege wegen des Krieges in der
Ukraine aber den ist nicht so die
südkoreanischen Rüstungsexporte sind
schon vor dem Ukraine kriegt massiv
angestiegen
[Musik]
das beweisen ganz deutlich die Daten von
Sipri dem Stockholmer
Friedensforschungsinstitut im 5
Jahreszeitraum 2017 bis 2021 stiegen
diese Exporte um 177% verglichen mit den
fünf Jahren davor wir haben es also fast
mit einer Verdreifachung zu tun damals
die höchste Wachstumsrate in der
Militärindustrie weltweit zum Vergleich
das war fast dreimal so viel wie
Frankreich im selben Zeitraum erreichte
die Nummer 2 in der Liste andere große
Exporteure wie China und das Vereinigte
Königreich reduzierten gar ihre
Verkäufer um 31 bzw 41%
[Musik]
ihr seht also die Zuwächse in der
südkoreanischen Rüstung sind nicht das
Ergebnis eines vorübergehenden
Aufschwungs und es handelt sich um einen
sehr deutlichen langfristigen Trend und
ihr könnt euch sicher vorstellen dass
derartige Wachstumsraten der
militärexporte nicht über Nacht zu
bewerkstelligen sind
dahinter steckt ein langer Weg
milliardenschwere Investitionen sowohl
von großen südkoreanischen Unternehmen
als auch vom Staat selbst schon seit
langem in Forschung und Entwicklung und
natürlich in die entsprechende
Produktion man kann sagen das Südkorea
seit Jahrzehnten dazu verdammt ist ein
extrem wer hat das Militär zu haben und
als Grundlage dafür eine starke
Rüstungsindustrie ein kurzer Blick in
die Geschichte erklärt warum
nach dem Waffenstillstand der den
Koreakrieg 1953 beendete lag die
südkoreanische Armee in Trümmern
praktisch entwaffnet und erschöpft war
sowohl für seine Verteidigung fast
ausschließlich von den Vereinigten
Staaten abhängig aus diesem Grund hießen
die Südkorea nicht nur 10.000 von US
Soldaten auf ihrem Territorium
willkommen Sonnenuhren auch zu
bevorzugten Kunden der
us-rüstungsindustrie das hat etwa für
zwei Jahrzehnte das südkoreanische
Militär war lange Zeit eine Art
verkleinerter Nachbau des US Militärs
und zwar sowohl operativ als auch in der
Kommandostruktur und auch was die
Ausrüstung betraf in den 1970er Jahren
aber endete sich das alles quasi auf
einen Schlag denn 1969 führten die
sogenannten Doktrin und die Öffnung
gegenüber China zu einem massiven
Teilabzug der US-Truppen aus Asien
hatten die Vereinigten Staaten 1969 noch
000 Soldaten in Asien stationiert waren
es 1971 also nur zwei Jahre später nur
noch
284.000 in Südkorea selbst reduzierte
sich die Anzahl der GS im gleichen
Zeitraum von 63
000 auf 43.000 und versetzt euch mal in
die damalige Lage Südkoreas angesichts
der Bedrohung aus Nordkorea war das eine
äußerst unangenehmesituation ihr müsst
euch vorstellen damals gab es ein viel
höheres Maß an Schikanen als heute
Entführung und nordanschläge durch
nordkoreanische Kommandos waren an der
Tagesordnung von der ständ Bedrohung
durch eine gigantische Armee unterstützt
von das sowjetunien
[Musik]
im Jahr 1968 zum Beispiel versuchte
überhaupt Korea den südkoreanischen
Präsidenten pactum dabei stürmten
nordkoreanische Spezialeinheiten das
blaue Hauses Präsidenten die Aktion
schlug fehlt der Angriff wurde abgewehrt
dennoch starben sieben südkoreanische
Soldaten da war es nicht verwunderlich
dass sie sagte der Rückzug Amerikaner
sei eine Botschaft anders südkoreanische
Volk und zwar dass die USA Südkorea im
Falle einer weiteren Invasion nicht mehr
retten würden und das obwohl sich die
Südkoreaner bei den USA für ihre Hilfe
im Koreakrieg revanchieren wollten indem
sie mehr als 312 000 Soldaten in den
vietnamkriegt schickten um andere Samen
zu helfen
der Rückzug Washington war also ein
herber Schlag fürsohlen das Bündnis mit
den USA war zwar unverzichtbar und
bestand natürlich noch weiter aber so
die Befürchtung es reicht allein nicht
aus um die wehrfähigkeit sicherzustellen
Südkorea musste sich also an die Arbeit
machen um sich aus dieser
sicherheitspolitischen Notlage selbst zu
befreien als erstes nahm man ordentlich
Geld in die Hand und steckte jeden wann
in die Waffen schmieden des Landes
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zudem erhielten die Rüstungsfirmen
riesige Kredite und Steuervorteile genau
das Gleiche geschah in der
Stahlproduktion und im Schiffbau sowie
in der Elektronikindustrie denn diese
Branchen galten als strategisch wichtig
für die Sicherheit des Landes und diese
gigantische Förderung kam nicht nur den
Militär zugute
[Musik]
sie bildete auch die Grundlage dafür
dass Südkorea heute zu den führenden
Industrienationen der Welt gehört aber
zurück zum Militär Schritt für Schritt
wurden die Südkoreaner immer weiter
unabhängig von Waffenexporten aus den
USA sie schmiedeten sich ihre Waffen nun
einfach selber am Anfang begann sie
natürlich mit einfachen Dingen wie etwa
gewähren und der us-lizenz aber sie
steigerten sich mit der Zeit und bieten
heute einen der umfangreichsten und
fortschrittlichsten Kataloge an Waffen
und Ausrüstung an aber was genau macht
Südkorea in Sachen Rüstung eigentlich so
besonders dass sogar NATO-Länder im
großen Stil dort einkaufen ja diese
Frage werden wir jetzt unter die Lupe
nehmen also aufgepasst
[Musik]
die Geburt eines militärischen
schauen wir uns doch mal die
Geschäftsbeziehung beim Waffenhandel
zwischen Polen und Südkorea etwas
genauer an diese ist so etwas wie ein
Musterbeispiel das uns verdeutlicht
warum die Koreaner bei den
Rüstungsexporten so erfolgreich sind
warschau hat allein im Jahr 2022
aufträge im Wert von 14,7 Milliarden
Dollar an den südkoreanischen Militär
Komplex gegeben und die kommenden Jahre
geht das in ähnlichen Größenordnungen so
weiter ihr müsst euch klar machen dass
einer der größten NATO Armenien in
Europa hauptsächlich mit südkoreanischen
Waffen ausgestattet sein wird Polen
brauchte Waffen um sich zu verteidigen
und genau das liefern wir wir Koreaner
wissen das ohne Waffen zur Verteidigung
das Endergebnis eine Tragödie ist
insgesamt wird Polen in den kommenden
Jahren über 1000 Kate to Black Panther
Panzer und 48 FFH die Kampfflugzeuge
kaufen dazu kommen fast 700 km einander
Panzerhaubitzen und
2883 Raketenwerfer über diese werden
euch gleich mehr erzählen aber die Frage
ist jetzt warum Umwelt Polen seine
Streitkräfte ausgerechnet mit
südkoreanischen Waffen ausrüsten nun
dafür gibt es vier Hauptgründe der erste
ist die beeindruckend kurze Lieferzeit
weniger als drei Monate nach der
Unterzeichnung des
kaufvertrags-polen bereits die erste
Lieferung es ist wie Amazon Prime für
Rüstungsgüter die Südkoreaner haben es
geschafft die ersten zehn Panzer und 24
Rekordzeit nach Polen zu liefern die
große heile hatte natürlich auch einen
Grund so hatte Polen dadurch die
Möglichkeit die Ukraine weiterhin mit
sowjetischer Ausrüstung aus polnischen
bestimmten zu liefern 6 dezember 2022
erste Lieferung schwerer südkoreanischer
Waffen geht nach Polen das schnelle
Tempo dieser Lieferung ist angesichts
der russischen Aggression und des
Krieges in der Ukraine von
entscheidender Bedeutung polnische
Präsident andre du da aber wie ist es
möglich dass die südkoreanische
Industrie so schnell liefert nun die
Antwort die industriellen Kapazitäten
sind einfach vorhanden das Land hat eine
riesiges industrielles Katze Zentrum mit
einem sehr produktiven militärsektor der
auch ständig für den Bedarf des
südkoreanischen Streitkräfte produziert
[Musik]
ein weiterer Vorteil ist dass Korea auch
ein enormes Potenzial für die Lieferung
von Nachschub hat ein Beispiel moderne
Waffen sind komplexe hightechsysteme
ausgestattet mit einer großen Menge an
Computerchips und wisst ihr was Südkorea
ist der zweitgrößte Halbleiterhersteller
der Welt gleich Hinterteil die
Südkoreaner haben sich im Grunde zu
einem one stop shop entwickelt die
Rüstungsindustrie hat starke und stabile
Beziehungen zu ihren Zulieferern
einschließlich der Chip Hersteller das
ist der Vorteil einer großen
industriellen Basis man hat einfachen
Zugang zu allen Arten von Bauteilen und
Zubehör es ist auch einer der
Hauptgründe warum Polen mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit in zwei bis drei Jahren 180
Panzer des typscape 2 und 212 hoch ist
das kein Nein aus koreanischer
Produktion erhalten wird aber Moment mal
war nicht eben von 1000 Panzern und fast
700 hauptsitzen die Rede tja gut
aufgepasst aber diese Differenz hat
etwas mit dem zweiten großen Vorteil der
Südkoreaner zu tun denn sie sind sehr
flexibel bei der Vergabe von Lizenzen
für die Herstellung ihrer Waffen im
Russland Geschäft ist Geschäft und hier
nutzt Südkorea seine Chance
denn die Vereinigten Staaten sind
außerordentlich restriktiv wenn es darum
geht ihre moderne Militärtechnik
außerhalb des Landes herzustellen
Südkorea ist aber ganz anders es
schließt gerne Lizenzverträge ab in
Polen läuft das dann folgendermaßen ab
nach der Lieferung der ersten Panzer und
Haubitzen werden die Polen die
Herstellung der restlichen 800 Panzer
und 500 Haubitzen selbst übernehmen die
Herstellung in Polen hat dabei so einige
Vorteile es ist nun mal für Länder mit
hohen Rüstungsausgaben einfache diese
vor dem Steuerzahler zu rechtfertigen
wenn die Herstellung der Waffen im
eigenen Land Erfolg und damit
Arbeitsplätze geschaffen werden
es handelt sich um eine klassische
Politik der Industrieansiedlung die der
Wirtschaft und den Arbeitskräften zugute
kommt außerdem kann Polen die eigene
Produktion der Waffen und die Lieferung
an die Truppe so schneller abschließen
da man nicht von einem Zulieferer in
einem weit entfernten Land abhängig ist
wir haben es also mit einer klassischen
Win-Win-Situation zu tun Waffen
Arbeitsplätze Know-how und eine
industrielle Basis für den Käufer und
satte Gewinne für den Verkäufer klingt
doch gut oder ein dritter wichtiger
Vorteil ist der Preis
[Musik]
südkoreanischer Waffen sind billiger als
die andere westlicher Länder nehmen wir
zum Beispiel die Panzerhaubitze K9 der
hangar-gruppe zwei ihrer wichtigsten
Konkurrenten sind die französische
sessare und die deutsche panzerhauptet
2000 bei allen dreien handelt es sich um
dich logisch fortschrittliche Haubitzen
mit ähnlicher Leistung und dem NATO
Standard Kaliber 155 mm und jetzt kommt
der Preisvergleich während einer
französische Sache etwa siebeneinhalb
Millionen Dollar kostet und die deutsche
Panzerung bis zu 10 Millionen Zahlen
Polen für eine koreanische Thunder
haltet euch fest nur 4 Millionen Dollar
das heißt weniger als die Hälfte des
Preises des deutschen Modells und ihr
werdet euch fragen wo ist der Haken an
der Sache nun gibt es nicht es ist
lediglich eine Frage der Kosten oder
Größe der Produktion der eine warschglas
auf der Creme hat einen Nachfrageschub
ausgelöst so dass osteuropäische und
skandinavische Länder jetzt Schlange
stehen um mit Hannibal über seine
selbstfahrenden beschütze zu verhandeln
das Unternehmen bietet äußerst
konkurrenzfähige Preise in der
Vergangenheit hat die koreanische
Regierung etwa ein Viertel der
Artillerie Nachfrage gedeckt so dass das
Unternehmen über enorme Skalen Vorteile
verfügt die Preise der deutschen
Konkurrenten sind etwa doppelt so hoch
das südkoreanische Militär hat aufgrund
der Bedrohung durch Nordkorea ein hohen
Bedarf an artillerieausrüstung und
Zubehör das hat dazu geführt dass sowohl
das Militär als auch die Hersteller ihre
Artillerie Ausrüstung ständig erweitern
und aufrüsten um im Ernstfall immer
weiter und präziser gegen
nordkoreanische Bodenziele Feuer zu
können
aber bei den Deutschen z.B ist das
Gegenteil der Fall ihr Militär ist durch
jahrelange desinvestition geschwächte
und ihre Rüstungsunternehmen haben viel
weniger Nachfrage vor Ort das macht es
viel schwieriger profitabel
Produktionslinien zu attraktiven Preisen
aufrecht zu erhalten es ist einer der
Gründe wieso Waffen aus Deutschland
meistens sehr teuer sind übrigens wenn
ihr mehr über den traurigen Zustand der
deutschen Streitkräfte wissen wollt
schaut euch doch unser Video zur
Bundeswehr an dass ich euch verlinken
werde so und habt ihr eine Idee was der
vierte Vorteil der Waffen aus Südkorea
ist denn das heißt ja so oft nur teuer
kann etwas taugen aber Südkoreas Waffen
sind billig und gleichzeitig auch gut
sehr gut sogar
das koreanische Equipment hat einen Grad
eine Raffinesse und Komplexität erreicht
der nicht weit hinter vielen der besten
US-Waffen liegt schauen wir uns doch mal
wie versprochen als Beispiel den
cake-toohandelte hinein shamura
kettenwerfer an dem Kate hinein
bezeichnete Experten als die beste
Alternative zum Heimat der Amerikaner
und er ist etwa 20% günstiger
hergestellt wird der Raketenwerfer von
der Hand war die Fans company einem Big
Player des südkoreanischen Industrie
dieses System ermöglicht es Raketen
unterschiedlichen Kalibers und
unterschiedliche Sprengkraft mit
derselben Ladung abzuschießen denn die
Raketenwerfer sind zwei unabhängige
Kapseln unterteilt was diese Variation
ermöglicht der Chango kann also während
eines raketenabschluss ist sowohl im
sättigungsmodus arbeiten als auch im
Präzisionsmodus das heißt mit einem
abschlussvorgang werden zum einen viele
Raketen abgefeuert die ein großes Gebiet
abdecken zum anderen werden beim selben
Abschluss auch einzelne Raketen sofort
die ihre Ziele ähnlich präzise die
heimatstreffen in diesem Fall mit einer
Genauigkeit von etwa 10 Metern das
System vereint praktisch die Fähigkeit
der russischen gradwerfer die wie eine
Feuerwalze wirken mit der chirurgischen
Präzision des heimats panwa hat für
seinen Raketenwerfer eine breite Palette
von Raketen entwickelt mit
unterschiedlichen Kalibern und
Sprengköpfen und unterschiedlichen
Reichweiten mit einer einzigen Ladung
schießt der Werfer z.B bis zu 40
ungelenkte 131 mm Raketen auf ein
weiträumiges Gebiet die Reichweite
beträgt dabei etwa 36 km und ein
Abschlussfeiern dieser 40 Raketen ist in
weniger als einer Minute machbar und
wenn präzisionen weiter Entfernung
gefragt ist kann sie auch 12-239 mm
Lenkraketen auf Entfernung zwischen 160
und 200 km abfeuern eine Reichweite die
der Hersteller in den kommenden Jahren
noch vergrößern möchte
[Musik]
und das sind nur ein paar der Optionen
denn das System ist wesentlich
vielseitiger als heimats weil mehr
Raketentypen zur Auswahl stehen außerdem
entwickelt ein was ständig neue
Projektile die im Shin Moon verwendet
werden können
[Musik]
dazu gehört die 600 mm präzisionsrakete
Katie ssm2 die eine Reichweite von 300
km haben wird mit dieser Rakete wird
schon Mode der direkte Konkurrenz des
taktischen Raketensystem der Amerikaner
auf dem marktwirt Rüstungsgüter sein
etwa im Jahr 2030 soll dieser Rakete auf
den Markt kommen zurzeit ist der K21
bereits bei den südkoreanischen
Streitkräfte im Einsatz wurde in die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
exportiert und an Polen verkauft Polen
hat einen Vertrag über 288 Einheiten
abgeschlossen und dafür sogar seine
heimatbestellungen reduziert dass ich
diese wohl erheblich verzögert werden
denn die Nachfrage nach Heimat ist nach
den zahlreichen Erfolgen gegen die
Russen weltweit in die Höhe gestellt auf
jeden Fall erlebt die südkoreanische
Rüstungsindustrie gerade eine goldene
Ära und angesichts der Weltlage ist das
vielleicht erst der Anfang wie gesagt
weltweit steigt der Bedarf an allem was
fliegt schwimmt fährt und gleichzeitig
schießen kann und wie wir gesehen haben
kann Südkorea zu sehr günstigen
Konditionen sehr gute Rüstungsgüter
liefern ja im Westen kann man verdammt
Bruder darüber sein dass dieses Land zu
seinen Verbündeten gehört Südkorea wird
den besten bei der notwendigen
Aufrüstung helfen können und es hat
gleichzeitig selbst zu einer mächtigen
fest zu werden die Chinas Einfluss in
der Region einnehmen kann und auch zu
diesem Thema interessiert uns was ihr
denkt glaubt ihr das Tutorial sich als
einer der größten Waffenexporteure der
Welt etablieren kann was haltet ihr
davon das Rüstung derzeit wieder so ein
Bombengeschäft ist eine Welt voller
Waffen ist ja eigentlich eine verdammt
traurige Entwicklung aber wie sonst soll
man der dauernden Bedrohung durch
totalitäre und zu allem entschlossenen
Staaten sonst begegnen habt ihr
vielleicht eine Alternative Idee auf
jeden Fall hoffe ich dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch was dabei gelernt habt falls ja
geht uns bitte einen like teils und eure
Freunde und vergesst nicht das Abo mit
Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit uns halt dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen Link dazu findet ihr in
der Beschreibung unter diesem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]